>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Leonard Bernstein: Hi, everyone.
I'm Lenny Bernstein.
I'm a Health and Medicine
Reporter for the Washington Post.
And I have the honor of introducing
our next author, Dava Sobel,
author of "The Glass Universe."
Before we get there a couple of
things I'm supposed to tell you all.
Obviously you're spending
the day here in the cool
and dry convention center,
instead of out on the mall.
And we're very happy about that.
The Library of Congress
puts this all together.
They make it seem easy every year,
get people in and out of here.
And you get to see a lot
of your favorite authors.
It's a very large financial
undertaking.
And it's only made possible by the
generous support of our sponsors.
This presentation is sponsored
by the James Madison Council.
We can't take for granted that
this event will continue to exist.
So we'd like to ask you to consider
making a contribution now using your
cell phone.
You can do it right now before
you leave this presentation.
You can send a text to
make a one-time gift.
And the details are on the screen
and on the back of your program.
A couple of things, sort of house,
some details about
what will happen next.
Miss Sobel will have a
signing time from 3:00 p.m.
to 4:00 p.m. of her new book.
And she's in Line 5.
So if you want to go get your book
signed, please do that after this.
Dava Sobel has been writing
about science as a freelancer,
a New York Times reporter
and an author since 1970.
She's best known for her
1995 bestseller "Longitude:
The True Story of a Lone Genius
Who Solved the Greatest
Scientific Problem of His Time."
Her book "Galileo's
Daughter" was a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize
in Biography in 2000.
Much cooler she has seen nine total
eclipses now, counting this one.
She's an eclipse chaser.
And even cooler than
that the asteroid
"30935 Davasobel" is
named after her.
[ Applause ]
During the Q&A that comes at the end
of the presentation you might want
to ask how you get an
asteroid named after yourself.
Her latest book is called "The
Glass Universe: How the Ladies
of the Harvard Observatory
Took the Measure of the Stars."
And it reveals the extraordinary
discoveries made by a group of women
who analyzed and interpreted
the observations made
by male astronomers via telescope.
So please welcome Dava Sobel.
[ Applause ]
>> Dava Sobel: Thank you.
It really is a thrill to be here.
I was a little mystified by the
title of these sessions though.
"Contemporary Life."
I'm wondering if it's a
euphemism for science.
Maybe. Maybe.
I also want to reiterate
the title of the book,
which you see on the slide.
There it is.
It's "The Glass Universe."
It wasn't an intentional play
on the term "glass ceiling."
But I find that it often gets
called "The Glass Ceiling."
And it's really not about that.
It is really about a collection
of photographs of the sky
that were taken on glass plates.
This is 19th-century technology
when photography was
brought into astronomy.
And the medium for taking pictures
was an emulsion-coated glass plate.
And these half-a-million plates
are still kept at Harvard.
They're still used.
In fact, they were in
the news this week.
I don't know how many of you
saw an article about a discovery
that was made in the
late 15th century
by some Korean astrologers
who saw a guest star.
And recently some historian
astronomers really wanted to figure
out whether that had
been a nova, a supernova.
And they thought they would look
at the Harvard glass plates,
and try to figure out if they
could see that object again.
And they did it.
They found it on several
of the plates.
So that's my bow to
contemporary life.
[ Laughter ]
But now to return to
the late 19th century.
I first heard about these
women more than 20 years ago.
And I was fascinated to think
that there was a whole roomful
of women doing astronomy at Harvard,
which is certainly not
a place people associate
with wide open opportunities
for women,
especially in the 19th century.
So I thought that was
definitely a story.
And I was even more excited
when I saw how many pictures
there were of the women.
So I will try to show you as many of
those as I can in the time we have.
And part of the reason there were
so many women was the broad-minded
attitude of the very young director,
Edward Pickering, who took over in
1877 when he was just 30 years old.
And he had been teaching at MIT.
And he was really a physicist.
And, so, people were worried what
sort of job he would do as head
of the observatory, because
he wasn't that interested
in doing what established
observatories did,
which was really study
the mapping of the sky,
the orbits of the planets and
asteroids, comets, and be largely
in the service of navigation.
But he was interested in
the physics of the stars.
And he started doing things
that other observatories were not
doing, including hiring women.
And there was a strong prejudice
against higher education
for women at this time.
Although Pickering
had been very open
about letting interested women
students come to his course at MIT.
And this book "Sex in Education, a
Fair Chance for the Girls" sounds
like something that
was good for women.
But actually the argument was that
going to college was dangerous
for women in the college-age
years, because devoting all
that mental energy to schoolwork
would cause their reproductive
organs to atrophy.
[ Laughter ]
And Pickering was also
able to laugh at that.
Thank goodness.
And felt that women had already
demonstrated their ability
to do astronomy.
When he arrived at
Harvard the daughter of one
of the former directors was working
there, the sister of another one.
So there were about six
women already employed
at the observatory as computers.
And he saw no reason
not to keep that going.
This is what the observatory
looked like.
It was a very attractive
wooden building on a hill
about a mile from Harvard Yard.
There were two telescopes.
And then the building that has
the three smokestacks was the
director's residence.
So he was right there.
He could just roll in and
out of bed and be at work.
This was the big telescope
under the big dome.
It is still there.
It's no longer used.
Can't do much astronomy
from Cambridge.
Sometimes when it was in good
repair, and it will be again,
it's used for public nights to
have people come, and get a look
at the planets, and get
turned on to astronomy.
And this telescope was a
gift to the observatory
from the people of Boston.
So here's one of these glass
plates that I'm talking about.
Some of them were photographs of
unusual phenomena such as a comet.
Most of them are negatives.
So the stars look black
against a white background,
stars or other objects.
And the most interesting
use of the plates, I think,
was started by this couple since
it was actually an astronomy love
story, because the man, Dr. Henry
Draper, was an amateur astronomy.
Do we have any amateur
astronomers here?
Just a few.
Ooh, we need to get
proselytizing here in Washington.
And the amateurs were the ones
who could be at the forefront,
especially if they were
married to someone as wealthy
as an Anna Palmer Draper,
who was an heiress.
And she and her husband
worked together.
They took images together.
And he was the first person to
succeed in taking a photograph
of the spectrum of a star.
So the stars' light run
through a prism and spread
out into its component wavelengths.
And this was so important.
They were going to drop everything.
He was going to stop teaching.
He was a medical doctor,
but he taught.
And devote the rest of
their lives to this project
to photograph the spectra
of the stars,
and figure out why the
stars were different colors,
maybe how they worked,
what they were made of,
what were the chemical
components of the stars.
As recently as the 1840s,
1850s people had assumed
they would never find
out what the stars were made of,
because they were too far away.
So there was just no hope of that.
And now all of a sudden with
spectroscopy it was possible.
And Henry Draper said that the
spectroscope had made the chemists'
arms millions of miles long.
So they were all set to do this
when he suddenly contracted
pneumonia and died at age 45.
And she was determined to
see his dream realized.
And she was a friend of Pickering's.
Everybody doing astronomy was
more or less friendly then.
It's still a relatively
small community as you saw.
And she offered Pickering
her personal fortune
if he would do the work
in her husband's name.
And that's what gave him the
means to hire so many women.
So here is a textbook example
of a spectrum, of course,
long before color photography
in the 1880s.
This was what some of the
best of the images looked
like for the very brightest stars.
And most of the time the
pictures looked like this,
because Pickering figured out that
if he put the prism at the far end
of the telescope, instead
of the eyepiece,
he could capture hundreds
on every plate.
And then it would just be a
question of examining the plate
with a magnifying glass
or a microscope.
And you could have all
those spectra together.
So every little smudge
in this illustration is
the spectrum of a star.
And the black circle is
a penny, just for size.
So here are the ladies.
There's Pickering standing
in the back.
And this is obviously
a staged photograph.
But this is pretty
much what they did.
In the foreground is a woman
with a magnifying glass.
And she's looking at
an angled stand.
And that's how they held the
plates, which most of them were
about eight by ten inches.
And there was a mirror
under the stand.
And if the shades were
up in the room,
then the sunlight would come
in, bounce off the mirror,
and up through the plate.
So the plate would be illuminated.
And then she would be
looking at the spectrum,
and deciding what classification
it was, and calling that out
to a partner who would
be writing the notes.
You didn't want to be
looking at the plate,
and then turning to
write in a notebook.
So they had a very
well-organized system.
And their classification
system started
out just being letters
of the alphabet.
They would look at these patterns,
and arbitrarily decide, okay,
this pattern is a,
this pattern is b.
So at the beginning they had no idea
of really what the patterns meant.
Could have been any
number of things.
Different temperatures,
different ages of the stars.
It was an open question.
So this lady, who was standing over
the group in the previous shot,
became the supervisor, which
is remarkable considering
that she started at the observatory
working as a domestic servant.
She came on the resident side,
because she was in
desperate straits.
She was a Scottish immigrant,
had come to this country
with her husband.
But now he was gone.
And she was pregnant and
desperately needed a job.
And, so, she took this position as
the second maid in the household.
And the Pickerings immediately
recognized her intelligence,
and moved her into the
observatory, taught her how
to do computing and
analyzing plates.
And then they helped her go home
to Scotland to deliver her baby
with her mother and grandmother.
And they promised her a real job if
she would come back, which she did.
And she came back and
became the first woman
to get a Harvard University title as
Curator of Astronomical Photographs.
And she spent the rest of
her life working there.
Here's another one.
Antonia Maury was the
niece of Henry Draper.
And she was also a
graduate of Vassar College,
where she had eight
semesters of astronomy
under this formidable looking
lady with the telescope,
who was Maria Mitchell, the truly
first lady of American astronomy.
Here's another one.
Annie Jump Cannon.
The original women were hired to do
computing and to analyze the plates.
But Miss Cannon, who was a
graduate of Wellesley College,
came with so much experience
as a telescope observer
that she did her own
observations from the beginning.
And this drawing of her at the
telescope is from a children's book
about her called "Annie
Jump Cannon, Astronomer."
So here is a typical plate.
Miss Cannon became the one to
perfect the classification system.
And on the way to doing that she had
to juggle the alphabet a little bit
so that the system,
that is now in use,
the way the letters are arranged
is no longer a, b, c, d, etcetera,
but it's o, b, a, f, g, k, m. And if
you're wondering how I can remember
that it's with the mnemonic,
"Oh, be a fine girl kiss me."
[ Laughter ]
Which is how astronomy students
for decades have memorized,
they still memorize it that way.
Although now some of them say,
"Oh, be a fine guy kiss me."
Take your pick.
So she had a marvelous
ability to look at a spectrum,
and instantly understand
what that star was.
So she would [inaudible] there are
numbers written all over the plate.
That's how she worked.
She would put numbers
next to the spectra.
And then she could call
out a number and a letter,
and the people writing them down
just tried to keep up with her.
Obviously it's not for everyone.
[ Laughter ]
One of the great helps to
me in writing the book,
trying to really bring out the
personalities of these people,
Miss Cannon was a lifelong diarist.
And I got to work in the
Harvard University Archives.
These are the boxes labeled
"Miss Cannon's Diaries."
And it was thrilling
the day I opened that.
I also spent some time here
at the Library of Congress,
because a lot of the Draper
family papers are here.
And I did find in those folders
the guest list for the dinner party
that the Drapers held when the
National Academy of Sciences met
in New York City in 1882 proving
that Thomas Edison really was there.
Pickering wanted to
photograph the whole sky.
He had a tremendous vision of how
valuable a resource this would be
if he could photograph
both the stars visible
from the Northern Hemisphere and
from the Southern Hemisphere.
And he had a wonderful
assistant, Solon Bailey,
also Bailey's wife,
Ruth Poulter Bailey.
And he sent them to South America
to find a place that would be good
for carrying on the work down there.
This was their first
set up on Mount Harvard.
Didn't look too promising.
Eventually they really got it
together in the [inaudible]
of a thought to be extinct volcano.
Turned out to be dormant.
But they were there for many years.
And several of those
buildings house telescopes.
Although only one of
them is dome shaped.
You can have an observatory
with a slide-off roof
as well, as many of those are.
But inside the dome is
this gigantic instrument.
This has a lens 24
inches in diameter.
And it was made specifically for
taking these kinds of images.
And this was the gift from another
heiress, Catherine Wolfe Bruce,
who read about Pickering's wish
to create a big telescope to use
in the Southern Hemisphere.
And she just wrote him
a check for $50,000.
He was very charming.
[ Laughter ]
Here it wasn't all work in Peru.
Sometimes they had picnics.
Ruth Bailey is the one without
a hat in the foreground.
And then her husband is two
people away from her in the hat.
And they were down there for years.
They brought their child with them,
because they knew they were
going to be there for years.
Mostly they studied these objects,
which are called "globular
clusters."
Astronomers are very straightforward
about the way they name things.
You know, Big Bang, black hole.
This is a globular cluster of stars.
And there were a lot of them visible
from the Southern Hemisphere.
And a lot of them that had a
lot of variable stars in them,
stars that changed
their light over time,
which were of particular interest
to Pickering and the whole group.
And one of the things
they tried to do was
to count how many stars
were in this object.
A daunting task as
I'm sure you'll agree.
Henrietta Leavitt is
another one who came.
She was deaf.
Miss Cannon was also partially deaf,
but Miss Cannon wore a hearing aid,
and was able to go to the
opera and to concerts.
In fact, the Harvard Archives owned
many boxes of all the libretti
and programs she saved because
she was such a music lover.
But Miss Leavitt's job
was to look at the images
from the Southern Hemisphere,
and track the variable stars.
And she made a fascinating
discovery.
She was particularly interested in
this object, which is visible only
from the Southern Hemisphere.
It's called the "Small
Magellanic Cloud."
Got its name from Magellan's
round-the-world voyage,
because he was the first
person to mention them,
and say that they looked
like clouds.
They're actually satellite
galaxies of the Milky Way.
And she figured that
all the stars that were
in that body were roughly the
same distance from the Earth,
so that the stars that looked
brighter actually were brighter.
Usually when you look up at the sky
you can't tell whether a bright star
is bright because it's
extremely bright intrinsically,
or because it's very close
compared to the others.
But here in this object,
let's assume they're
all the same distance,
so the bright ones are truly
intrinsically brighter.
And she tracked that.
She published her findings.
That was the other
thing about Pickering.
He published everybody's work
under each woman's own name.
Always gave credit.
They were, all of them, world
famous in their own lifetimes.
So with her observation that
the bright stars were really the
brightest, she also noticed that
of the variable stars the variables
that got the brightest
also took the longest time
to cycle through their changes.
And that observation
enabled astronomers
to calculate the distance
to this object,
and then the size of the Milky Way.
And that rule, which was
for a long time called the
"Period-Luminosity Relation," it's
now the Leavitt Law, pass it on,
that's what Edwin Hubble used
to show that the little spiral
in the constellation, Andromeda,
was actually another galaxy,
another Milky Way, an
unbelievable distance away.
After Pickering died Harlow Shapley
took over at the observatory.
And he was intent on
initiating a program
of graduate education and astronomy.
That was not Pickering's focus.
Pickering's idea had been to
create information and share it
with the world, not
to train astronomers.
And Shapley felt it
was very important
to train the next generation
of astronomers.
And because of all the
interest in the women working
at the observatory several
heiresses had contributed money.
I've mentioned two of
them, Anna Palmer Draper
and Catherine Wolfe Bruce.
Another one, Lydia Henchman, who
was a relative of Maria Mitchell,
began a scholarship program that
enabled a young woman to come work
at Harvard for a year, and
then be able to go on to work
at any other observatory
anywhere in the country.
And they infiltrated
the whole field.
And, you know, I like to say that my
Harvard ladies are the grandmothers
of the hidden figures, because
that's why NASA was so open
to hiring women as computers.
It dates back to these women.
So these scholarships
came to be known
as the Pickering Fellowship
for Women.
And Shapley thought, okay, I'm
going to have graduate students.
I have to have graduate
fellowship money.
And the only money he had,
because Harvard University did not
support the observatory financially,
so the only money he had were these
Pickering Fellowships for Women.
And he thought he could stretch them
to use them for graduate education.
But not stretch them
farther than that.
So the entire first crop of
graduate students were all women.
Well, Shapley was at Mount
Wilson in California,
and he had gotten his
degree at Princeton,
and he came from Missouri.
So that history was his argument
of why Harvard needed a
graduate program in education,
because they had been embarrassed
having to hire a Missourian
from California, you know, instead
of promoting one of their own.
But his other interest, when he
wasn't doing astronomy, was ants.
And he published several scientific
papers about ant behavior.
And I just wish he could have lived
to see this cartoon
in The New Yorker.
This was not one of those contests
that asks you to supply a caption.
It's just that the caption
got cut off in the slide.
But the caption is, "Kind of
makes you feel small, doesn't it?"
[ Laughter ]
So here are some of
our graduate students
in astronomy, some
of the early ones.
The large picture is
Margaret Harwood.
She took over at Nantucket.
She ran the Nantucket Observatory
that had been started
by Maria Mitchell.
She ran it for 40 years.
And she got her graduate degree
before these fellowships were
instituted in California.
And the woman in the picture
with the globe is Adelaide Ames,
who came from Vassar on
a Pickering Fellowship.
And at the bottom is Cecilia
Payne, who came from England,
because she had been told in England
that there was no future for her
in astronomy in that country.
And she knew about
the Harvard women.
She knew about Annie
Jump Cannon's work.
And she met Harlow Shapley when he
was in England giving a lecture.
So she told him she really
wanted to come and work there.
And he helped her get
one of those fellowships.
And he pushed her to
be the first one to go
on for a Ph.D., which she did.
And because she had been
in the Cavendish Laboratory
at Cambridge she was the first
person who worked at Harvard
who really understood atomic theory.
And she wanted access to
the glass plates to be able
to calculate the relative abundance
of the different elements
in the stars.
That had not been done yet.
And as she worked she kept coming up
with a ridiculously high abundance
of hydrogen, which people
considered impossible.
You know, that many
of the same elements
in the Sun are found on the Earth.
And there was a widespread belief
that the proportions
would be similar.
So the fact that hydrogen was maybe
a million times more prevalent
than anything else, it
just seemed ridiculous.
So Shapley sent her dissertation
to the reigning authority,
who said that it was
impossible for hydrogen
to be a million times
more prevalent.
And, so, in her dissertation
she reported her result.
But conceded that it could be an
error, it could be spurious finding.
There could be some explanation
that no one had come up with yet.
It took only four years
from the publication
of her doctoral dissertation in 1925
for the entire astronomy community,
including the person who
had said it was impossible,
who did the research,
to convince everybody
that that was, in fact, the case.
That, yeah, it really
is almost all hydrogen.
This is one of my favorite
pictures of them.
Although it does give a sense of
maybe disrespect that they are lined
up like paper dolls,
although there are a couple
of men in the paper doll chain.
But these were some of the pictures
that really inspired
me to tell this story.
And I kept saying over and over
again I couldn't understand why
nobody had done it.
And it turned out that
there's really a lot of science
that goes on, the work that they
did, and what happened in the field
of astronomy over this time period.
And I spent many days asking myself,
"Whatever made me think
I could do this?"
But I hung in.
Here's Miss Payne.
She was also a musician.
The previous speaker mentioned
the connection between mathematics
and music, which is strong.
But I think it's even stronger
between astronomy and music.
Almost every astronomer I know
has some kind of musical bent.
So Miss Payne was an
accomplished singer and violinist.
And she also started in
Observatory Orchestra.
And this was a performance
of a spoof they did called
"The Observatory Pinafore,"
which used the music of
Gilbert and Sullivan.
This is how the plates are stored
today, if any of you are wondering.
These are two pictures of the
same young woman, Lindsay Smith,
who is the current curator.
So starting with Williamina Fleming
the curators have always been women.
And it's a big job.
And, as I said, there are half
a million of these objects,
and each one is in a paper
envelope, carefully barcoded.
There's a card catalog.
You have to be able to
get at the one you need.
And in the picture,
in her gray sweater,
she's looking at the logbooks
that were kept by the women
as they worked on the images,
and made notes about them.
This is how the plate
stacks is that,
this building was constructed
expressly to hold the plates.
This was a brick building,
because the wooden observatory,
the director feared,
was just a fire trap.
And as this collection amassed
everyone, not just at Harvard,
everyone in the world viewed it
as a unique invaluable resource.
And, so, a brick building
was created for it,
and definitely fireproof,
but as they found
out a year ago January,
not waterproof.
A water main burst
underneath the building,
and submerged about
60,000 of the plates.
But all is well.
The entire collection was in
the process of being digitized,
because the plates are still in
use, and it's awkward to have to go
to Harvard, and handle
these very fragile plates.
So much better if they'll all
be available online to anybody.
But the digitization equipment,
which was all custom built,
was also drowned in the flood.
But the insurance money
has paid for new equipment,
which is faster, better and cheaper.
And, so, they are moving along.
And they probably will finish the
project more or less on schedule.
How many people have
seen "Hidden Figures?"
Yeah. So, as I said, I do believe
there's a direct connection.
And the woman standing next to the
movie poster is Alyssa Goodman,
who's a Professor of
Astronomy at Harvard.
Her, what looks like a NASA t-shirt,
but it actually says "Nasty,"--
[ Laughter and Applause ]
And she is one of the people I
asked to be a technical expert,
because I wanted the astronomy
to be all correct, of course.
And she got completely sidetracked
by the story of the women.
And told me, "I've worked
here all these years.
I know these names.
But I always thought they were
doing something cute or quaint.
I never realized they were
actually doing science."
So she said she needed
to have me come up
and teach them their history.
So we actually had the book
launch in the observatory.
This is one of my very
favorite pictures of them,
also obviously staged, because
so many of them are here.
That's Margaret Harwood
sitting on the floor.
And Antonia Maury just behind her.
And toward the back is Miss
Cannon, too busy to look up.
Cecilia Payne is at
the drafting table.
And they were a great
group, very convivial.
They worked together
six days a week,
and they socialized
on Saturday night.
And I'm noticing from my signs that
we have only about ten minutes left.
So I'm going to stop here.
And ask you to come
up and ask questions.
I think there will be questions.
If not, okay--
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. Thank you very much
for your book, first of all.
I've started reading it,
and I'm really enjoying it.
>> Dava Sobel: Thank you.
>> And I just wanted to know how
you got started in science writing.
I mean I have an interest
in science myself.
But I haven't really
thought about writing it.
I'm a technical writer.
So I'm just curious.
>> Dava Sobel: Okay.
Well, I wish somebody had told me
about science writing when I was
in high school, because I was
always interested in science,
and I always liked to write.
And I had no idea that I
could put the two together.
And it was a long unhappy road
through college with
that split idea.
And I got hired by IBM
as a technical writer,
because they recruited on campus.
And I still didn't know
what I wanted to do.
But I learned quickly that I was
not a fit for the corporate world.
And I was going to
go back to school,
because the thing I really always
loved to do was write term papers.
So I thought I'd go
to graduate school
and write some more term
papers while I figured
out what I was going to do.
And I bumped into a friend of mine
who was working at
the local newspaper.
And she said they had an opening,
and why didn't I come
down and apply.
And, you know, it was such a
random thing to bump into her,
and then to go and follow up on it.
But that's what I did.
And I got hired on the women's pages
of the Binghamton Evening
and Sunday Press.
And within that first week I felt,
"So this is what I'm
supposed to be doing."
And it was great, because it was
the year of the first Earth Day.
So I was writing about
conservation issues, pollution,
genetic counseling was
just coming into practice.
So there was a lot of
science to write about.
And because it was the women's pages
nobody really cared what I did.
I had a lot of freedom.
And it was great.
We still have the women's pages.
You know, we just call them
"style" and "dining" and "living."
Yes.
>> How long did it take to
produce one of the plates?
And how long does it take to
digitize one of the plates?
>> Dava Sobel: Thank you.
Some of the plates are
very long exposures.
So they represent several hours
of telescope tracking time.
And it was very difficult
work to get good images.
There were automated clock
drives on the telescopes.
But they didn't always work well.
So the individuals who made the
plates really developed the art
of doing that work.
Then they had to be developed.
And depending where you were,
if you were in South America,
you had to get them
back to Cambridge.
And sometimes there were arguments
about should we look at them here
in South America, because
maybe something is interesting
and important in this
plate that we should follow
up right away while we can.
Whereas the women back in
Cambridge really wanted the credit
for making the discoveries.
So that became a friction
point at one point.
And as for the digitization
process, it took a long time
to figure out how to do it.
The plates all had to be cleaned.
So those markings, anything
that's going to be digitized,
all that has to be wiped off.
So all the plates had to
be photographed first,
so that the markings were
preserved in some way.
Some of them are considered
too historic to erase.
The equipment had to be built.
I think once they actually get it
on the machine the scanning
probably takes under a minute.
But I will, if you stick around
and give me your email address,
I will get you an exact answer
to how long the scanning takes.
Not very long.
And they do them a big rush assembly
line now to get it all done.
Thanks.
>> Thank you.
>> Dava Sobel: Yes.
>> Good afternoon.
I was just in the talk
earlier by the author
on "Hidden Figures,"
and now in your talk.
And yet today we struggle with women
and African-Americans in particular,
you know, and their ability to be,
not their ability to
be, their acceptance-
>> Dava Sobel: Their acceptance.
>> As scientists in
many of the STEM fields.
Are there lessons you've learned
that would be appropriate both
for those faculty who are making the
decisions of which women come in,
or which minorities are
allowed into programs,
or to the actual women themselves?
>> Dava Sobel: I think probably one
of the most important answers is
the presentation of role models,
both to young women looking
to have that sort of future,
and to people hiring to realize.
You know, most people can
name only one woman scientist.
And it's Marie Curie.
So to be able to show a whole room
full of people, a whole lab full
of people, is an important thing.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks for this
great presentation.
I just wanted to say that your book
"Longitude" is my favorite
non-fiction book of all time.
>> Dava Sobel: Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
>> I'm amused by your remarks
about how you got into your field.
My Jewish mother would
have called that the shift,
which in Yiddish means faith.
So your faith took
you to your career.
But that's not my question.
My question is--
>> Dava Sobel: Good, because I
don't have an answer for that.
[ Laughter ]
>> My question relates
to those plates
that had multiple stars
on one plate.
>> Dava Sobel: Yeah.
>> Now I understand you could
magnify individual stars
and analyze them.
But when you magnify an image
you lose something in resolution.
So I'm wondering did they
ever compare individual slides
of individual stars with the plates
that had that star among lots
of others to see whether you
actually did lose something
in the resolution when you looked
at multiple ones on one slide?
>> Dava Sobel: Yes, they did.
And they satisfied themselves
that it worked well enough.
>> Hi. Good afternoon.
Thank you for--
>> Dava Sobel: Hi.
>> Your talk.
A friend of mine from
college is an astronomer.
She works at Adler
Planetarium in Chicago.
And I've always admired
her brain and her success.
And I think she's great.
And, you know, we're at the
age now, we're in our late 50s.
Could you tell us like how like
the change for women in science
and astronomy, from the women
that you profiled in this book,
to now till, you know,
girls in grade school,
high school who might be interested
in going to the field of astronomy?
>> Dava Sobel: I'm not sure
I understand the question.
Can I tell you--
>> Well, what has changed?
And if someone--
>> Dava Sobel: What has changed?
>> Yeah.
>> Dava Sobel: Well, I think there
have been changes back and forth.
I mean a situation like
this in the 1880s of having
that many women working together
was highly unusual at the time.
And yet the work that they did
was acknowledged and accepted.
And the situation at
Harvard continued up till
about the start of
the Second World War.
After that there were
machine computers,
and less of an emphasis
on hiring women.
I mean Pickering was a
man of great fairness.
But he was also very practical.
A room full of women cost a lot
less than a room full of men.
It's still true.
So all I can say is may it continue.
>> Thank you.
>> Dava Sobel: I think the one more,
do we have time for
one last question?
Yeah. Great.
Perfect.
>> Do you know what the glass
plates were treated with in order
for the images to adhere
to the glass?
>> Dava Sobel: You mean the actual
composition of the emulsion?
No, I don't.
I hate to end on that note.
[ Laughter ]
I don't like to pretend I know
something when I don't either.
If you want to give me your
email address, I will find out.
And, of course, the
emulsion is one of the things
that people worry about, why
the digitization is necessary,
because eventually the emulsion
separates from the plate.
And then you're left with nothing.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.